you're watching another day of play for
all and is my great pleasure to be
joined today by Ed Boon who doesn't need
any introductions but if you know or
love Mortal Kombat I'm sure you know
exactly who it is a are you I'm doing
good thanks thanks for having me
awesome thank you for joining us and
dedicating some of your time to talk to
us about m'kay m'kay aftermath which
came out recently and and your kind of
career with the game first of all I
think it's polite to ask how are you
doing right now given the events of the
world and the isolation how's things in
ads well I think my world is probably
similar to most of the people at nether
realm you know working from home doing a
lot of meetings you know communicating
through all of the the tools that are
available the the zooms and the slacks
and the Microsoft teams and all the
different means of communicating still
to some extent adjusting even though
it's been like three months to this new
normal that we have what's it like to
have to launch something like after Mach
in the midst of this I imagine a lot of
the kind of camaraderie and energy that
a studio needs to get to the finish line
and then enjoy the fact that you've put
something out is not as easy to come by
so what's it been like for you and as a
team like what's the temperature been
like having launched this it was it was
different we were in a situation where
we were pretty much done with the main
content that was consisted in aftermath
you know the story mode the three
additional characters and we were in you
know QA testing and you know looking for
bugs pretty much wrapping things up in a
sense when everything hits so it's not
like we had to do a lot of motion
capture or you know content creation
part of the game even still I was
surprised how how the team rallied
together so well in the circumstance and
you know again our IT department was
like you know miracle workers how they
got us all working from home so quickly
what's the response been like too often
obviously it's something unique for the
studio
you guys have traditionally kind of
fought new characters and content around
that this is the first time you've
really fought a meaty story expansion
what's the reaction to that bin like and
what do you think you've learned from
doing that it's been great you know we
really kind of went all in and said
let's you know let's just really end the
story with a bang and do something
that's unexpected which like you said
we've never done something that before
we always try to do something new and
unexpected with every iteration of
Mortal Kombat just to really keep thing
people on their toes so without spoiling
too much about the game you mentioned
they end the story is that how you're
kind of like thinking of the story in
this game and off them off do you see as
a definitive end because obviously for
fans they've been tracking since the
reboot as we call it like you know the
kind of progression and it feels
cohesive but there's almost like a
definitive full stop at the end this is
that how you guys want to treat it yes
the story that we've told you know which
I guess you can summarize it as Lou
Kings journey in a sense in my head is
is is is done you know and we're not
gonna be expanding you know you're like
oh and then this happened and then we
reset again and you know like like it's
it's we really feel like like that's the
end of that timeline obviously the
franchise as a whole has had its own
twists and turns and that's something
that the modern narrative more combat
were very much takes into account but as
basically the father or one of the
fathers of more combat and Luke angle
always was emotional seeing him reach
the point where he's like a god now and
for me personally like like like you
said you know you know Mortal Kombat you
know the the idea of it was you know
myself and John Tobias we were like okay
let's do this game that that does this I
don't think we would have guessed in a
million years that you know 28 years
later the game would be as strong as
it's ever been and still going the story
element was such a minor part you know
the the description of Liu Kang and who
he was was just literally a paragraph a
short paragraph that was the extent of
it over the years we just kept layering
on it and
expanding on it and then it became like
this universe this this long-running
soap opera there's no way we could have
predicted that every once in a while
I'll go yeah that's right that that's
something we started you know it was
just Liu Kang was just a guy with black
pants and no shirt on that was it that
was who he was you know there was no
other detail there's an entire team of
people know who it belongs to them as
much as it belongs to you it's kind of
like you know you have to give way whoa
is I've been difficult for you not from
the standpoint of the studio so much of
what Mortal Kombat is right now you know
as it's evolved over the years has been
defined by so many significant players
in the studio and so I certainly don't
feel like you know oh I need to look at
every single component but when it comes
to outside of the studio you know that's
where I personally get a little bit more
protective we worked really well with
the people who did the Mortal Kombat
direct-to-video animated feature and
they really respected it and that was
that was a great experience but we are
very very protective of our child when
it when it leaves the studio MK 11 story
and aftermath especially and it really
doubles down on the time-travel function
and you know the the past few games have
had a lot of that but this one
specifically feels very dense and
time-travel and because of that it's a
lot of engaging nostalgia like it for
players right seeing old versions of old
characters as someone who was along for
the ride in creating that how was it to
see like the era where you were really
hands on meeting the era where another
group of people are hands on what was it
like to experience there's my Liu Kang
talking to a new teams new generations
Liu Kang that was absolutely by design a
big part of when we make a Mortal Kombat
game is we know that there's a
significant part of a audience who's
been with us the whole time and they
have the warm and fuzzies for this
version of Liu Kang or they have the
warm and fuzzies for the you know mk2
version of you know a rock or something
like that so we purpose
we put as many nods to previous versions
of Mortal Kombat characters or back you
know a lot of times we'll bring back up
an arena and show it off with the latest
technology
you know the Deadpool or something like
that and that's absolutely by design as
was the story you know what would it be
like to see young Johnny Cage
interacting with older Johnny Cage you
know that's absolutely by design I think
it really hit me hardest when it was
like Sindel Shao Kahn Shang Tsung
kind of like going into face Kronecker
and like two revenant smells like this
is basically Mortal Kombat one two three
versus Mortal Kombat 40 which was like
this is amazing yeah yeah that's that's
that's not an accident you know we kind
of there's like a fanservice type of
component that we always wanted to serve
I know this is a question that you could
almost think with me but I feel like
it's pertinent given the way aftermath
ends and do you guys still have interest
in exploring Mortal Kombat outside of
the fighting game genre I mean I know a
lot of fans always bring up Shaolin
monks but not without spoiling it again
the ending or aftermath is basically the
setup for Shaolin monks again they're
kind of like another adventure between
2000 and is that something that you want
to do are we gonna get a more combat
rhythm game whatever it may be - the
exact words of your question when you
say do you think about it absolutely
absolutely we're thinking about all the
time we've had you know like you said
we've had a couple of mortal combat
Shaolin monks was a really good example
of it the process of making it happen
has been a little bit more challenging
you know we've were really just one
studio and we did a game called
injustice and that did well and then we
did a sequel it did even better and so
unfortunately we can't do you know all
the things that we want to do at the
same time and so there are a lot of
logistics that have to be worked out a
lot of you know details there's timing
there's you know there's a million
things that are involved on top of do we
want to do it one thing I want to get
kind of take on is like the I know
people are always asking you about the
you know the celebrity or the guest
characters and how cool they are but I
put it to Dominic in this way and I want
to play the same what's it like to be
creating a game which is effectively a
child's kind of play session come to
life because I remember fun you know
fond memories of having a Robocop figure
and a predator figure and just smashing
him together and being like fight fight
fight and now you guys are basically
making that as a game is that something
that you've kind of like intentionally
done right they just kind of fall into
that word were scratching that same
ditch for us that you were when you were
a kid you know taking over a pup figure
in an act and determined it was bigger
yeah no we did it with predator alien
you know Jason Robocop Terminator it is
literally that it is literally we are a
bunch of people who grew up watching 80s
and 90s 2000s
action movies and thought to ourselves
wouldn't it be cool to see Robocop
fighting terminator you know like it's
it's no more complex than that one of
the other things that want to talk about
is bringing back characters that you
know or maybe lesser-known on haven't
been explored properly like fusions a
big one for this one and shiva's well
what was the thinking behind that and
are there any specific characters that
you wanted to bring back that you
weren't able to hope that people will
still love and and look into enjoying a
bit more there are there always are you
know if you count there's probably about
80 there's probably more now Mortal
Kombat characters that we've released in
various versions some are staples -
Mortal Kombat sub-zero scorpion Regan
Liu Kang some are not as frequently seen
Fujin striker Shiva and not that they
not that we don't love them as much but
we always have to have Scorpion and
sub-zero and a horrible comeback and
because of that it's almost like a like
a revolving door
you know everybody's everybody gets
their chance in the Sun and then maybe
we give somebody a break and then when
they've come back players are that much
more happier to see them are you excited
about where the technology for next gen
is going I know you guys work closely
with Unreal Engine and modified engines
around that based on what you've seen so
far and the whole load kind thing what
do you think that means for stories the
way you tell them because obviously you
guys are great at framing stories and
seamlessly moving between combat and and
like cinematic moments but what do you
think what excites you about next gen I
think everybody's excited about you know
the expected jump in you know fidelity
of the graphics you know frame rates and
lighting effects and all that stuff
that's that's to be expected and I've
said this you know multiple times before
is I'm actually arguably more excited
about the the best load times than I am
about the graphics you know there's a
when you've made enough games you've
kind of developed a understanding of the
limitations that you have to do with
every feature you know there's a finite
amount of memory finite amount of time
that it takes to load into that memory
and you you you work around those
restrictions you know and try to mask
that load as elegantly as possible
suddenly a lot of that burden has been
lifted and so you need to clear your
head and go oh there's a whole new world
of things that we can do that I suspect
even now some developers haven't thought
of that you know a new ideal come to
mind maybe in the second generation or
wave of games that comes out for these
systems and that is going to be I I
think potentially you know the biggest
thing that will change in terms of games
design for these next-generation
consoles
sure should be interested to see what
that does for fatalities I'm sure that's
final question I always like to find out
what people who make gains are enjoying
themselves so what are you currently
watching listening to reading playing
that you're really enjoying and what you
excited to check out in the future I
haven't been playing nearly the amount
of games that I want to play I have a
number of games that are on the kind of
list to play I'm odd you know because of
the situation we're in with everybody at
home and everybody you know I've been
spending a an odd amount of time
watching like videos on how to you like
YouTube videos instructional videos on
how to do a number of things that I've
been wanting to learn over the years
whether it's a software program or
playing the guitar or music theory or
some things like that I've been really
focused on on absorbing a lot of that
stuff and trying to keep up with all the
games you know as far as what what's the
big thing you know what's big game that
is getting old all the attention right
now right
is there anything coming up that you're
excited about game ways that you want to
see more off well it's obviously always
great to see the the single player it
you know story narrative driven games
also always you know that's a category I
hope doesn't go away
edy thank you so much for your time it's
been really enjoyable chatting to you
and getting your kind of insight on
where more combat is and is going so
really appreciate your time for more
play for all videos please check out
games.com and youtube.com slash GameSpot
and we'll see you for the next one
[Music]
you
[Laughter]
[Music]